there has been a lot of talk lately
about the fiscal cliff which sounds very
dramatic and what i wanted to do in this
video is at least lay out the numbers so
that we're all on the same page and then
in the next few videos think about the
implications or how the negotiations
between the president and congress might
actually work out so the first thing to
frame this conversation is just where
the budget is right now and so let me
draw a little graph
so let me make this axis right over here
represent
our budget and i want to make it as big
as possible so that we can get a little
bit of granular detail on how much
the budget might move based on how the
negotiations work out so let's say that
this line is roughly 4 trillion dollars
long so that's 4 trillion then halfway
would be about 2 trillion and then in
between 2 and 4 you got 3 trillion and
then 1 trillion
would be right over here 1 trillion
and then i'm going to do some bar charts
to show the different the different
scenarios and as i do this keep in mind
the size of the us economy the us
economy is approximately
15.5 trillion dollars so that is
roughly our gdp depends on which year
you're measuring
but that gives us at least a frame of
reference for what chunk of gdp we are
talking about when we talk about
the
the federal budget
so let's start
let's start with the 2012.
let's start with the 2012 budget so in
the u.s government is spending 3.6
trillion dollars
so let me make my graph a little bit
more granular so this would be 3.5 so
3.6 is going to be right around here
so let me draw
that and i'll do it in i'll do this
purple color for the expenditures
so this is how much
the federal government
spent or i guess is spending in 2012.
so
just like that
all right
there we go so that's expenditures
now you are probably aware that we don't
have all of the revenue we didn't bring
in 3.6 trillion in taxes so this right
over here is 3.6 trillion our revenue
that we get through tax revenue and
other things is somewhat less
it in 2012
was on the order of 2.5 trillion so i'll
draw that right over here so 2.5
trillion i'll do it in this green color
so this is how much revenue
revenue was brought in so let me write
this down
this is
2.5
trillion
now let's think about how much might get
spent under the different scenarios so
first i'll lay out a rough approximation
of obama's budget proposal for 2013.
so obama
in
2013.
so on the spending side he sees or he
would like to see spending go up by 200
billion
so let's see this
so on the spending side we're going to
add
200 billion
and the next few videos we could talk
about the pros and cons the arguments
for and against something like that
so let me draw that
so relative
relative to the 3.6 we're now at
we are now at
3.8
so this so you have a spending increase
of
so plus 200 billion that gets us that
gets us to 3.8
billion in total expenditures
if my best estimate of what the
republicans in congress would want so
let's write let's say republican
republicans in 2013 is that they would
actually ideally want spending cuts from
these levels
so let's draw that out and roughly on
the order of about a hundred billion
so roughly on the order of 100 billion
they might even want more than that but
let's just go with that for now so that
gets us to a budget of 3.5 trillion so
that's about that right over there
three
three point
five trillion so once again relative to
relative to 2012 you're going down by a
hundred billion let me make that clear
you're going you're subtracting 100
billion
now in the fiscal cliff scenario the
fiscal cliff scenario
the spending will be similar to the the
republican ideal right over here so let
me write this over here fiscal cliff
fiscal
cliff
we are also spending we are cutting on
the order of a hundred billion in
government expenditures
so let's draw that so at least on the
expenditure side and these are all very
rough i'm sure they're republicans who
would agree and disagree with this but
i'm trying to get my best sense of
of
of kind of an aggregate view on things
so
the fiscal cliff we are also cutting
spending
by a hundred billion
by
one so we are cutting by a hundred
billion
now let's go to the revenue side of
things and all of these scenarios for
and just to be clear the fiscal cliff
that's also for 2013. in all of these
scenarios we get the same revenue
from that we got in 2012. so let me draw
that
plus we get about another 100 billion
from the growth in the economy as the
economy grows and even if your tax rates
are held completely constant you're
going to get more revenue for the
federal government so you get about a
hundred billion you got a 100 billion
from the federal government and so that
gets us to 2.6 trillion
2.6 trillion without
without changing anything so let me just
shade all of these in really fast
so that takes us to 2.6 trillion
so shade that it went in
shade that one in
and then
shade
that one in
now as you've probably heard on the news
obama
would like to extend the bush tax cuts
for the middle class and he considers
the middle class those uh who are making
less than 250 000
for a family but he would like to
not extend the the bush tax cuts on the
rich and he would like to actually
include a few
tax increases also on the wealthy and so
you would get an increase of revenue
under obama's plan of 300 billion
300 billion this is once again very
rough
there's probably 50 60 billion that i'm
not fully accounting for but it'll give
you the the rough picture so this is 300
billion
and what obama's doing here or what at
least in the proposal as far as i could
glean none of this is that simple
what they're talking about right over
here is extend tax cuts
extend tax
cuts for middle class
for middle
class
which my best reading seems like we
would lose a little under 200 billion of
revenue but then we keep the tax cuts or
we we we let the tax cuts on the wealthy
expire so that gets us 200 of this and
then there are other tax increases and
and other like removing loopholes and
whatever else that increase this to 300
billion so let's compare the deficit
let's compare the death so this gets us
to in the obama scenario we end up with
2.9 2.9 trillion in revenue so let's
compare what the deficit did from 2012
to obama's budget plan
so in
2012 if you take 3.6 trillion subtract
out 2.5 trillion
there is a gap
there is a gap of 1.1 trillion this is
the deficit this is how much the
government has to borrow in 2012. under
obama's budget what would it be for 2013
well we're spending 3.8 trillion
we are getting 2.9 trillion so
you have a gap of 900 billion
900 billion
he so there is some deficit reduction
although the deficit is still quite
large the deficit reduction's 200
billion 100 billion of that came from
economic growth and then the rest is
coming from
or or a good chunk of that is coming
from increased taxes or letting
depending on how you view it either
increase taxes on the wealthy or not
letting the tax cuts expire on the
wealthy
now let's think about the republican
situation
well you have 2.6 trillion in revenue
and you have 3.5 trillion let me write
this down
you have 3.5 trillion
in
expenditure and once again you have on
the order of a 900 billion
900 billion
900 billion gap so in terms of deficit
reduction these things look pretty
similar you have a very similar deficit
obama is increasing spending and he
would argue that he's investing in
things that might help stimulate the
economy or invest in america for the
future and then he's making it up by
letting the tax cuts on the wealthy
expire for the most part the republicans
want to cut spending but they're also
letting the tax cuts continue so you
essentially have the same level of
deficit reduction
now i think we are ready to talk about
the fiscal cliff the fiscal cliff where
you're spending a hundred billion less
and then we are also letting all of the
tax cuts for both the wealthy those who
are earning at a family level more than
250 000 and for the middle class we're
letting them all expire
and so
you have the revenue increased by 400
billion
so this goes up by 400 billion
so plus 400 billion and so that takes us
roughly once again this is all rough to
about 3 trillion in revenue and 3.5
trillion in expenses and so your deficit
under the fiscal cliff scenario the
deficit
is going to be 500 billion dollars
now you might say hey this is great
everyone's talks about the deficit the
deficit is a scary thing we are
borrowing from the future and all that
why are people so afraid of the fiscal
cliff the reality is is that if you take
500 billion out of the economy so 100
billion through spending cuts and then
100 bill and then 400 billion from tax
increases so the government is
de-leveraging but that money is being
sucked out of the economy and you could
argue that there's kind of a multiplier
effect as well that that might endanger
what's already a very precarious
recovery that the recovery is really
just starting the recovery is just
starting to happen and if we were to
suck all of this money out of the
economy this that's what the argument
would be
then that might throw us into another
recession or it might make the recovery
that much weaker in the next few videos
we'll discuss that in a little bit more
depth see what people are saying the
impact might be and what the arguments
might be in either case